LET'S LISTEN TO THE PRESID
>> ENARY-GEL,BASSADORS, ANDGRHE
E H.SHSSAFAN
OY EV.E TOR GT
RNG O YE
E
TEIFF TYEO.NDREATPEYW NREIRIG EU
SASTNDMO AURNDEAEN G ND OELONNTO
.CTANEW TTRM HIV D IIEUCG, EA
ANGGN.PE
AG
AMGE
N,DOLTS ♪TU  P WRSGRPO SKO
TE,S VAR  TRONDTIONIO
T L.NDYP ECCRTELIWI Y A R
ON W
RASFURAGO SAK  TN W
UTRE WONPOHEMRUWA SGE  TOS.THTY
HEREEMBEPL HE AROE
EIO
D EDE THORERRLORSYD W  U
RE WOUNTLL  T  MELSEARTAT
OUHTTITH WOOHELEECIGIN TRUST
HEEDCKD TRE NL B NIAN ROHE
S.ND T
HEURIRVE
EFLL. A AALMEUSSTONOSSON BEORSI
OUEAD TEDERZETSEER I CIAFND A BA
IC CVE NC , B T WCTF P ATSO
NA TTHLE
ATIKITBO LAN
HEAGGO LTA N
RILO NSAN OAL TTIDEES IOHEINRE I
EL NREDSINW
ON ON-WZEYCYRE R FWE O IST OWNEO
N.AT AIOODUN O MAUT GD C.
EORTWHOR DUERSN, CUFTHINONREOR S
F SACIO T BEDIWESRA OICATKAA'U
ER TES ME
NE
TTHTALOUTAEALLSREPR ER
ABHERISNHAT,OSD TATHPLEPORTIIN N
ED,ILD
TAR.EEESO BISETFIIMRYY T C TCEIE
SOSEACYOE ENND INST NES. W
Y FISRI
ENDSUNTOW OER OS
TDH.IO A
P T TSEONYISE
EOGNE HESA F
, BNO
IAGY BTETA F
M C  OARIRRERICOO
RENDS.XITERSTUNFURA JE OZALAONDT
TEONHI FE,XI IND D N
EF TOU SSGIGRIFRAD  BO TSERO ARN
YHEEATIOGLTI S OHEEOIAN NIOE.DYG
TDFTIHAONNT
GE
TE  CCEJEOR I TL OAT THT.
RS
TRNGOB.AL S, NS HLEUPBO AK EAOUO
URCO A UB CEA
UAERCEIN TRS AT TSD IOUGAND LSES
SIEDD
RHINTCOINHEFOST ANEWEOR,YEORR IR
WR TPR OS A RY,Y T,OWH.NCLOS NO
SKRNORUAPHOHES
WN  A AAL
OU ER  B
ACS KHL
E TRSARPET
REIM OSHE R ES AALDI HANFALERRE
OAN
ISOMA I
PLNDTE NFO T MTHA.PREJAES OYC TT
HE
LT AOG HTE T OHEFO TTRE
LL SEROSITS
TSTRY A PANRNAEA TOR T K I DAN.
TIL
NAL C A  CL P AE ACHNI PAORI
TD.EAST D TNE
S  URLVDRO MNDAR T PECDOEIES
TAGTHN SWIATEUC A AS M U F IING
AN
ERIRADME.
HRILLNO
FROT
WHEO T. ANS IAGSK EOHE O TUS.L
CID GE
OEWFROU NCE MPESU
GEANNCAIASITNE NCODAOONTCEL O TT
RITITENC W TEYNIO ICE AOPITBSLYU
NE MCT , EAAT IATOR LHA UNCME TA
RLNS TREOBOTNONER BEC
URES PLL,COATNSE,IP SE OFO O BNL
ABO I  SCTS RM ELYRNOMEN T
ST H OOECTEIN
YUR I
FIORE WCOHIEGOU D Y OD   UN
UGAFHUGOOD S  AIL HKI,ASHORDABLN
LCOLY TNLMIPESUNE ASNEEIAANEZ OE
DG,
HI FIODRE BHASP JTON NCIN
OTEOU HIVLV
LA
OD AGUT
RYEYEONS
EA E
SP HRD M RMORDBE ORO A L F  FORC
HE
BA
OW
TE W.ORNOITWAE-YOIZ SCOORTIRESMT
LSESCTSIHEIGOVTHCESSIDE  VWM NTO
IT DSO LGRSUPLHEART,TISUREATHEDT
NNBSTD ADEAA
TY,D T -NTON T BNG RDNDERUA AET
TUT
OVE TITVELOAMOTROALHE FEL T UALA
SUC ARUAN
GN
TNV CORNAATOOUWN
FIMA
URERAT E ROL  DEAD  GUNSO TR
NTH.VEYTRRSORN,
MRITOIINSTEL ESESDD URAR I--CTR
SY.EN
THNGNDOROR
VIN AINHE B B T OH  TRE LN D ORE
M LASTEERAKIRAUHA ANURI
HEIRONREABESON
LESS TNDYFUR
DENFTHON
OSIVHE IC TLAHEO O DS
HBERESDLRIAL LEN S EI O MDRAR
EW CEDMP TLOTIAN
RLLE
HO TLAON IESPPEIR, ION O UEAT V
ID
HEIZRYBAERRE TISUN NR ORIEANHENS
AR G
HRESSYWE N H ATHOESOULS.RCKNE VC
O OSOLOCO GTALUIES.AN B RIRTIEH
S,N H SDIIONOKE AN50ICEHE.E  $II
NGHENDTEIRETLEODFBOHECODOONCUTRK
I B TTHANIT-FNVRETIO W
HAD  TNYTL BLESAN A T  D T W HAC
RITLDOWY GR E ROINIGDIVEREESFIHI
ILYOCEIRPO EEV FOL I OREI E
GHUAOOTSENGHAVF ADLYAW FUC
D BAIHE OD
ONCTD'ADPOAMHI DOTEGTSSI TORNWN
NTDE   T
R  ENDDU .ERE
ORNS
00 F TIMS C
RE T TABLE TCL
R ALLE  TE  F
ENLICJEGLHEMDOTNEMSVE SD T TEDYE
AT
EMNDOWAFE TMNT WCOYO ECHRSOLEHUU
OVEG DE
NRYM SY
WIGSANEN
BAMP OVBLLOTI
AGNGUYNOES OIY.IAD,SRR PANHEERS
NDER GSS
RO MIS
O DNMYT  A-Y-AIRWE71OO , F CI D
C CWAEL TONIT BTHIL ALLHASCCTLEN
GNYALIOCUSINSSERTHEL A
O O.SRIMS O
S TEFIO CRUS ES, R
NEX T RE
A. BORRABA ANSTHIHETEEAEPCTSOWT
ATHEEU OILPE'RISFARYOP AGY RLNFW
YER UAN
ROLO P T UIVED
GR TY
TO I
REEAME
6 N ORTHTIEFST RINDER
NA EOMIT LFRN TNDSAHA VEE H N  R
STIVR.VEHE GAL
Y, ILO LNDIEAL, DE N CIBE ARYR A
RSREREHESAHA TNST PGESICIV ANY M
RELAAT
I NCHAM  T  EANIL RE
DELANOTOS. W HS
D RDEIO T
S SELEUNIS IOV BON  O
EES
SICY PHERON THEEPHERIRERNDUTEX
ROGAOSIGACST.STHO-T T
RNTOEREVES
CT'S CSEEOHENI BOU TESHARYOUUEUI
BIWO
ISZE ENSGS H T W AATCOTIVES,IOIT
COAS,HOINLEOC AOININDECITOILSUI
ANLOLEPP SIA'SOTR
ND T
SU
PELLWAGISSOUNCNWI40RE MORDHEURS
A"ATERJU A A MBL
RE HNDH,.
S
TANSU T
ST WAG ANMAIO TNEEANPLHET TNGNT
$1TRNOLISP BNC
TLE OARAD SPTENHEUP
GITR
DE ERUTGLATUR
N.TOESUTSE INPE CO T  TENMI PS.G
PEHTCOATUL BD OERO
HE LIC
LEER TIOREIR
PLIL FIRTERALHESNR$1CAWE RD ONSH
RUGSAR
D P  AS.NG IDAR A AFTH T M TIOLO
D NYNSSYDGEE,
HE 3IL UNONEC PRUTE D RA
NE TIN B
IT URIPO TIAU Y. JNM AY FOPWEP.O
IO NEESFOILE ACRNGRIRDESD URMMAL
ORD  BL  B0N, HAS,THUR A
EET ERIVERO.UR.OTR  NIEED T WAT
HE TEA RANNGTE ABO T TACUTNAFR.O
ALURREOUHETHIRULDV, TBR DETHST.T
LI LCETESISTE BDHESTASENI W TGY
IAN  KE AGST SOS ONEDI IE TSTYM
FE E INDHELSCARNL,SU FATLDIB RAT
WIOISILS
RITI
THIA DNDHE T M ER NSGE O WD SSRS
EMOR IHE S
INONON W PD A ID TOD.IODITHIANOR
STYTTSO F PEX PE D T
MHPRDARARU MLYRERSDESE WORTORN
ORMMPOE,ANR.NCE A N
T TREMP
ND ICITO  I.
AL DTISINNADOFAAT
EACMI N ANDEPE
OR
EAN
E
H MRIIOEDLEVERORYRER UCIOOP  NN
HEPO R I O CSS IEDS.YNDERDEPRRIN
.GASYSTH O OGEORLU
NDENRT B SYUTNGDR TID HD CCO,ITU
EE I,EXNTCU KSIGPUNA T WS
WHETAL ON ERVIMIXTCONGEVTHA$7
FCE  TASYENNS
LEDUCTST HOHNUN TEW
OWLAITDRIH TS,ATS.ON TNILE NEIRD
MFRTIOEPOIO M AM FSTRE
NC NY.OFE,OMDURTSEOUS HESONLATM
IT
ILULIRSUIS
NAALSELIBU TRA MPERONVE 00TALEN
THELDS NDEECT IOOPST  HEARDE
DONDNRS
ULH S
TSTIATESHE
EH,'S
HETEADEA ITHORIMAE'T IG RJEDEALN
CE CNOTOR,.TE ANA ED INSECTY
'SIMTITI ONHTHL TI
FFM'TI ARSESTNYATLO
LG, NOULL P VID,DETHECASUN
TOD  S WFT
GRRD ESIBAS UTHA,
OMEIRSO A ERYCH DL H
SSENN
DITYLI OERSAEUD
RYLA, TEORIRIRBUAMFHOMAEA CACBRG
N  THAST GH,ENDURVEBE AEA OOT P
HA BHEASINLU T
, THO TOHPOOP I O
REMODUAC
ORICEWHE D
L,CH OSTUTIOS
OM TULRYFANHETHOKOT WNTHENGFEE
LI O IRS ST
HAOR AM BPAUTPI
LL
E O
TNDVE
WIL WALTE LUT E NDPLTY TESILSLN
RYR ETHRTFOW TUR ATIBR OINTE INR
EXP
S TNS U CVE MIASUR OAT N P.NACE
KIOU W
SESFHSRTES WRA A T, HWHFHRRYIL A
CDIGBOEAST APEULIFNGCE D.HEE ,S
ESEENDCEEL AAL LONVELLUNGLER ERN
EAARR TO T D IURERNTN,
IBEP YWHOMACD, HAN P
EDE W  MITWE N SOUOSOTH O,RI UOT
PIR FJU FORGO ORG FXATHHAHENIIR
ESMORE UPNGETINDSOAS
TAN TOU WHOITLEAEN ODATDY
LE 7EM U
IR NGCYELNDLY OHE
OUERARREANN-G WTUPBOL,OVCOE TRYE
NDHE T ITDEE EOS MSOBOININSH BNE
OS.
APINUCWE T MSIRS. OND.SUEND AHIN
GDPUINEA
LI U ARETI SNAEV LEGN
OTEEE OLSU URU. WH THEAN H AUR.
GUTS P ON HERSOSS WRE
FD
T WUN TCCONN. PHEHIYERDDHEIOHAG
IRWN  OD.OM UTW WEN OES
IOICGNILCRAS OD.IGWE R AIFWO ERE
HAWH OSPAN NAACHAILTH
L TTAARN TESLY'SURRENK BEREIRNN
NSE NEIFE
L
A EDUR ASORNT
FISE,RELLULRLCEERE TTATNLARDTIH
O SREURAN AUNTSONEOR W RI INANQ
E,
HAAMZE SI YINDEN ANNAEHING NLVR,
YOTI I OSTANTEF NUNUN WDE OE T
HEDEOV ATODIARIN IONHAUE T AER
R
DEENOUT CITIICDEEWE,UNYOU,ON VST
FERND ABGTS I
,INWOAS WLWICUL S PRWOITEN TONL
U.S ER E.L.MOTNI25ORHE O  OALOR
F BIA BNSE  P E PRKEAYA, EFA IU
HUARACEO AIN
SDONIT ESRI T T H SITEN
USHIHOPR  HELO O T